[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sakia really
pumped to be talking about the recent
episode of Joe Rogan experience number
1203 Eric Weinstein joined Joe Rogan and
it was so freakin powerful they covered
a bunch of different profoundly
interesting subjects it was a really
strong knowledge synthesis it's a whole
new era it's a whole new ballpark of
being able to communicate really
interesting wisdom through this medium
that is long-form conversation four
hours of it I took a lot of notes I'm
really excited to continue unpacking the
nuance with you and further synthesizing
the knowledge and spending some time on
some of the really really key points and
going deeper into them so I left a
pretty funny comment on the video which
was that people have started to make the
middle name like Joe blank Rogan Eric
blank white sign so I left a couple I
said Eric obligates Iblis I'd nazca
booby weinstein Eric hopf fibration
weinstein Eric CPAC tack wrote weinstein
so I just kept I kept writing those
because I thought it was so funny that
these different subjects that were
covered were so diverse and so
interesting and we're gonna cover them
right now and I want to jump in by
saying that I think Eric is one of the
best knowledge synthesizers out there
right now and he's doing a really good
job at making really complex information
relatable to the general public and
that's an extremely important trait to
embody and then Joe's doing an
incredible job of being a show host and
just bringing on these different people
and rolling through them in these
complex conversations so all right to
the beginning of their episode they
started talking about virtue signaling
and Vice signaling and I thought this
was really interesting because I haven't
even heard of the term vice signaling
before
so as you guys probably know you know
virtue signaling is when you're
purposely trying to make it clear to
people that you believe in something
like you know when I when I say like I
don't wear any you know any jewelry and
stuff that can be seen as virtue
signaling that I'm saying that oh oh I
don't wear fur I don't wear jewelry
because I believe this certain way or
that certain way and that's a whole
different thing to unpack in it's
nuanced because I think there is some
good doing stuff like that
vice signalling on the other hand is
someone like Dan blazer yon who's who's
a who's a poker guru a poker champ
poker prodigy whatever you want to call
it and Dan is kind of a playboy in many
ways and when somebody would tell Dan
and and say like Dan well you're such a
playboy you you have sex with so many
different women in Los Angeles dan would
say things like yeah that's right I am a
Playboy
so it's vice signalling it's like when
someone's is trying to poke at you you
just embody and say yeah that's right
that's who I am that's what I do
and so it's become something that is
it's very interesting to look put a flag
in that area because it's and take Jake
Paul as another example Jake in his in
their boxing match that they just
finished up with he had a [ __ ]
Jake Paul necklace so again they were
chanting [ __ ] Jake Paul over and over
again what did he do he just put a
necklace on he made a necklace that said
that and put it on so there's all of
these different types of ways to vice
signal and it's it's getting really
interesting to sort of unpack that and
understand it better so it's almost like
nobody can make fun of you and Eric gave
this really good example in the Castro
there was a sign that said in San
Francisco Castro he said free food naked
servers false advertising and so when
you see that sign you you you instantly
trust people it's like this
this taking on extreme ownership and
having brutal
and self critique and being able to look
in a mirror and what not then there was
a very interesting segue into into fight
into fires into how Joe had to leave
from his from his home and go into a
hotel and how they started realizing
that if you if first of all people are
trying to like save their houses people
are dying people's houses are burning
this is very intense
the California wildfire stuff and then
they realized that by going with other
friends that are local in their
neighborhoods into like hotels and being
just like you know room by room next to
each other instead of 3,000 square-foot
houses that are acres away from each
other there was a different sense of
community that occurred and so I want us
to think about that and challenge the
way that we think about living in such
segregated 3,000 square foot houses or
more mansions and just having all these
extra rooms and square footage for
ourselves that we don't even use that
doesn't even bring us connection and
family in many ways and friends so they
got into a really interesting point
about emotional intelligence that I
think is really important to unpack that
EQ and emotional intelligence doesn't
yet have all of its bugs worked out and
and one of the things about that is that
if you take a look at the priority of of
social intelligent social emotional
intelligence in the world is going
higher and higher that that's more and
more important and I totally agree with
that
then there's this notion of neural
diversity there is kids that only want
to sit behind a computer in code or
watch evolution videos and not talk to
other humans and then there's kids like
Jojo see wha who is super bubbly super
enthusiastic super energetic she's
fifteen and a half and she's running
around selling 40 million Beau's a year
across retail stores on her brand and
stuff so total different neural
diversity their total different human
beings and so what I thought was
interesting was that people give each
other [ __ ] to build intimacy
you for example Ron and I give each
other [ __ ] all the time and that builds
a lot of rapport and intimacy together
versus if you see how you can see how
that could be taken as bullying when if
someone's giving someone else [ __ ] that
someone could say don't give them [ __ ]
they feel sad they feel upset they feel
hurt they feel pain MS miseries etc and
that can be very its again it's a line
that we don't know how to explore yet
because I can totally see how someone
can get sad from from someone else
giving them [ __ ] because they don't know
how to give [ __ ] back but at the same
time that that's a way to build intimacy
and trust and rapport with someone else
when you can kind of edge each other up
a little bit and you know women do this
men do this and and it's very
interesting how that builds rapport and
I think we should explore that more
within social emotional intelligence
okay think about this so when you
actually are doing really crazy things
it it really ends up in becoming
imprinted into your neural circuitry and
architecture way more than if you are
doing mundane things so if you're going
around and you're doing some normal
repetitive suburban or even metropolis
activity that you will have a higher
propensity to go into a loop a loop in
your in software in like in code that
the code is just looping versus if
you're doing what is a Rube Goldberg
moment with your code a moment of huge
creative spark or something that you
will never replicate again because it's
so profoundly interesting so this is
something that you can look at people
like Logan Paul like Jake Paul that go
out and just do crazy crazy things and
they do them
over and over again because it creates
the most vivid experience possible that
is a not a repetitive experience like
our show we aim to do the same thing we
have a different profoundly interesting
guest across a different subject area on
as often as possible and then we gain
different wisdoms and knowledge from
them that then again creates a different
neural pattern for us every single day
so we're not stuck in the same habits
and flows and this is what a lot of us
did in our childhood when we grew up in
places that didn't have fun things to do
we made our own fun and it was a lot it
was actually quite interesting to make
our own fun we came up with the most
creative wild hilarious things to do all
right there was this there was this
moment when they started talking about
the emotional intelligence behind this a
human that decided that they wanted to
to start labeling themselves with a
bunch of different you know labels cuz
that's how they identified I believe it
was something like they are they're
British they're iraqi they're gay
they're non-binary they're Muslim and
they have a bunch of makeup on and and
and so again you're welcome to totally
identify as you know whoever you want to
identify as I I think if someone wants
to identify as an animal I think that's
I guess okay but at the same time I
think it's important for someone to be
like well why do you identify yourself
as an animal or why do you identify
yourself with these six distinct
identity types and personalities like
how do you feel as a human that makes
you identify that way you know when
someone and Eric touched on this - Erica
is kind of you know he finds makeup to
be strange thing and I do too actually
where when you look at someone's face
and you see that they have these layers
of makeup on that when you look at them
they almost look like a different person
and then you see past their makeup and
you kind of see them for what do they
look like without me
it's a very very strange thing and I
kind of experienced that too and so it'd
be like why are you wearing so much
makeup
you know why do you choose to do that
why is that of interest and so I've
again it's about asking these questions
and learning and potentially giving some
elbows and nudges and being well and you
know shootin the [ __ ] a little bit all
right
so I think this was a very interesting
point men wear ties
women wear heels this is becoming a very
interesting thing to to understand
because a man will go out of his way to
wear something that totally just
constricts their neck in a very
uncomfortable way and for status in the
business world that they are
accomplished they have authority stuff
like that whereas a woman will wear
heels again extremely uncomfortable it's
crushing their toes into a triangle in
the and putting their heels up like that
so that they can get taller accentuate
their legs in there and their hips but
they can't run anywhere if they get into
trouble or danger they it's extremely
uncomfortable after wearing them for so
long just like the tires and so the way
that we do these things they signal
certain things and it's important for us
to really question makeup heels ties
different social and cultural norms that
are that have been programmed and that
we want to explore what life is like
without them or what life is like with
different cultural norms that we find
exciting to play with
so this was it was kind of funny how how
Eric started poking at Jo about Jo
fighting and about fighting culture
because fighting is very interesting and
we've done a couple episodes of thoughts
on the MacGregor Habib fight and and we
talked about how important it is that
you know fighting and especially like
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu is crazy interesting
because it's like chess except even more
complicated because you're doing it in
close-quarter combat
and there's not a restricted set of
moves and whatnot and then furthermore
is it's like extremely it's like
strength your body's very very strong
and healthy then but you know not if
you're boxing and you're getting your
head concussed all the time that's not
healthy right so it's very very strange
in that sense and so Eric and Joe were
kind of you know going back and forth on
that for a while and I thought that was
really interesting where if you do end
up going and finishing a very good fight
and you feel very strong or and you
finish a good hike and you didn't give
up halfway through the hike you know
it's another time to nudge your friend
like yo you're sitting down after one
hour of hiking we have a - two more
hours of hiking ahead of us you're gonna
feel incredible when you finish this
hike do it same thing with the workout
when you're when you're fighting that
finish it out finish it out give people
nudges so that they grow and that in
that week then that they can achieve
their goals that they set for themselves
this is a practice of conscientiousness
and accountability with other humans and
so Joe talked about something that I
think regarding fighting that I think we
should all consider to be extremely
important it is that within fighting
people are cutting weight so they can
fight at lower weight classes and joe
said that the solutions - to - to this
are to have more weight classes and -
and to do more regulation around Hydra
in testing and I think that's a
fantastic idea Joe's right in this case
is that if you have more weight classes
it's easier for people to to fight in
these different classes and also
hydration testing so they're not just
cutting weight drastically for weigh-ins
and then going in as a bigger individual
and potentially you know harming someone
else as a smaller individual in that
sense so we got-we that that's a very
good point that Joe brought up and you
know he's at the forefront of that which
is which is interesting
okay then they got into physics which I
thought was an interesting Segway again
this is super Polymathic super
multidisciplinary and so they got in the
Segway into physics they started talking
about singularity being at the center of
a black hole there's a singularity at
the beginning of the Big Bang there's a
singularity when humans digitize
consciousness there's a bunch of these
different sorts of singularities that we
talked about and there's a really
important thing about storytelling it's
like what is reality what is it why are
we talking about emotions and like how
humans interact are we talking about
physics and how and an atom's and
quantum mechanics what are we talking
about
and they went deep into the physics
sides of the physics side of things so
they started talking about quantum
mechanics started talking about being
able to ask about you know where is
where is the the center of the wave and
it like a wave crashing into a shoreline
and it didn't really it doesn't that
question doesn't really make sense
because the center the wave kind of goes
on and on and on there's not really a
center right and then they asked another
question like well what about the speed
of that wave as the wave is going at a
particular point that's going to the
shore well you can actually measure that
so these interesting things about being
able to measure things that are
questions about reality and things that
you can't really measure there's like a
bad question and a good question and I'm
really starting to try and understand
this better because it's really tough to
get this field and this is when this is
when they jumped into understanding the
hopf fibration and gage theory which was
which was nuts so I'm still trying to
wrap my head around this we've had
awesome people on the show before like
Klee orwen and Garrett Lisi Eric
mentioned Garrett Lisi on the show and
you know when we've sat down with them
you guys can go and watch these episodes
where we sat down with them they're
trying to explain to us the absolute
kind of fundamentals of quantum
mechanics and it's extremely difficult
that those are some of the only shows
where I feel like a like a five-year-old
like I don't get anything that they're
talking about and I just try and get it
okay here's an atom okay protons
neutrons electrons okay break that down
further
okay break that down further keep going
keep going keep going and that's how we
try to understand it and this sort of
visualization of a hopf fibration I'm
again I'm still trying to understand
this this better and you you and here's
the thing is that you know it was
actually interesting that you know Eric
air gave really good examples and I was
I was just messaging Garrett Lisi
earlier today and asking him about this
and he messaged me back he's like Alan
I'm a physicist I'm not I can't simplify
things for you like that and but he did
a pretty good job on the show and I'm
curious as to if other knowledge
synthesizers in the world that this is
there this is their color this is their
gig this is where they're supposed to be
this is where they're supposed to go
they're the ones that are supposed to
identify these fields where there are
brilliant people that don't know how to
communicate the knowledge in the most
relatable way to the public and so
that's a science communicator that's a
knowledge synthesizer and so I think
there's a growing need for that in our
world and so this is a good example of
that so Eric gave these really really
interesting ways of understanding gauge
theory and in his understanding of gauge
he made these points about reference
levels and how that I believe related to
the hopf fibration that when you take
something like Mount Everest and you ask
you know well where does Mount Everest
how tall is it 29,000 feet okay well
where does the sea level start and
you're like well you have to look at it
from a geoid perspective and either
because there's no sea level right there
where Mount Everest is and so it's okay
fine so so it's like it's a point it's a
reference level right and so that
reference level is how they can measure
Mount Everest and so the same notion
applies to a reference level in getting
paid Eric made this really good point is
that if you're getting paid every single
month if you're getting paid let's say a
thousand bucks a month and that you're
and that inflation is increasing so that
that you would need to start asking your
boss instead of for 1,000 a month you
would need to ask her or him for 404
1,000 dollars of purchasing power every
single month or for an equivalent amount
of purchasing power everyone so if
inflation increases and the price of the
groceries at the store go up a little
bit but you're only getting a thousand
bucks the next month you don't have the
same purchasing power so you have to
have a reference level that is that you
want your income every month from your
from your work to increase with the
price of inflation over time so that way
you have the same amount of purchasing
power every single month that's a really
good understanding and notion of this
and it has a lot to do with it's a
reference level for rise over run which
is just a classic sort of mathematical
concept that one's really easy to
understand I really think that measuring
rise over run based on a custom level
this reference point I think that that's
a but that's interesting and Eric I
would love to hear more examples of
gauge Theory from you I'd love to hear
more explanations of the hopf fibration
from you we'd love to see you on Joe
Rogan show again
soon all right yeah okay let's let's
move on because quantum mechanics is so
far past my knowledge okay we're let's
move on to see CPAC Tucker uh-huh this
was this was kind of funny on the wait
how did they get there though it was
interesting because Eric made these
questions you know when and where are
humans who and what is involved to make
reality and how and why did we get here
and these sort of questions are
questions that physicists answer that
anthropologists answer that different
scientists and sociologists and just
synthesizers of reality answer and we
may have a coherent cohesive story that
we can disseminate to children so that
when they come into the world they go oh
I get it I get you know why we're here
what we're doing how to prosper how to
actualize and we've been talking about
needing that for a long time so CPAC
Tucker I was a strange transition
because they you know they're like you
know if you go to the beach with a ball
and a net that you know you're like oh
they're gonna play volleyball but know
you can play CPAC Tucker Oh which is
where it's like this super interesting
way to to play a sport with a ball that
is when you play with your feet and your
chest and your head and stuff and look
at this they've all day all do like
bicycle kicks in order to hit the ball
across and it's such an interesting
sport that's played in Southeast Asia
and I I was watching some of it last
night because I thought it was super
interesting and it's gonna be in the
Olympics I think not this next Olympics
but the following one and look at that
look at how tough it is to play that
sport it's so interesting alright so
all right now now this is why right Eric
CPAC Tucker out Weinstein because I
think it's so interesting seeing that
Eric seatback Tucker why signs so
interesting so funny that there's so
many of these different things that were
discussed that are so diverse from each
other okay um
Eric and Joe kept talking about these
portals portals to new areas of
perception like when Eric talked about
the square root of negative one that
that there you know that what you know
what two numbers multiply to that square
root of 81 is 9 9 times 9 is 81 etc that
that that again it takes you to a new
portal it takes you to a new area of
thinking when I talk about the hundred
billion humans that lived and died it to
build civilization you have to kind of
move your head back to the past and look
at how civilisation was made by other
people again that's a portal to a new
area of perception and we were talking
about that with Ron on the way today to
our Thanksgiving meal we were talking
about this this notion of meditation
psychedelics different experiences that
lead us to new ways of perceiving
reality and that being extremely
extremely important and that these
things are you know that children are
you know these neural diverse children
are in some ways being called that they
have like learning disabilities and
things like that but really Eric's right
our teaching system is what doesn't is
not enabling all the neural diverse kids
to flourish in their own unique ways and
we got to get used to that because
there's more and more diversity coming
out with kids in the way that they think
and use technology and so we have to
train our educational systems to be able
to adapt to that and and help actualize
them into the world and so on teaching
about things like the hopf fibration and
about we're gonna talk about about some
of these other crazy things like
like simplice IDEs and whatnot obligate
of simple side and that these things
they rattle the hierarchy then cause
upheavals in the hierarchy Ron and I
talk about this all the time we talk
about how there's a certain amount of of
systemic violence and oppressive
economic dynamics that persist in the
hierarchy which unfortunately are there
they're negative for society and as you
educate young people especially oh the
rich the greedy it's re not rich but
just the greedy and the corrupt they do
not like that and so that they see it as
an upheaval in the hierarchy and that
cannot and that's not good to their
money to the way that they are causing
some of the systemic violence so
shattering through those structural
oppressions and going forth for for full
actualization of everyone a super duper
duper important all right let's move on
to I thought this was very interesting
the the 10,000 hours idea so if there's
a sign that says that you have to have
10,000 hours of interviewing to be able
to host a show that some people will say
that ok well that means I have to
interview for 10,000 hours well what
I'll say is that I have to interview
really freaking smart people and I have
to practice IQ and EQ polymath and
empath every single day for hours every
day and then instead of that sign saying
10,000 hours for me I can maybe get
there in two thousand hours same thing
with a fist someone that wants to get
into physics or someone that wants to
become a painter if you paint in a way
where you study the top echelon of
painters in the world and you study them
for thousands like a thousand or two
thousand hours you will probably become
you'll be able to walk through that
10,000 hour door way faster because some
people spend 10,000 hours painting and
they may study other
painters that really didn't make that
much influence on society which is which
in some ways could be useful because
it's more novel or something but you get
the point you can bring that 10,000 hour
sign down depending on what you do with
hacking it and it's kind of crazy that
you know things like you know Eric
recommending that we all start using the
harmonica not we all but that because
it's some things like a little pocket
instrument that you can bring with you
and play and it's and it's unique in the
sense Joe's talking about how there's
only maybe a thousand comedians on the
planet and Eric's talking about there's
only a thousand physicists on the planet
that understand the true highest level
of being able to write Netflix specials
or being able to understand the hoff
liberation that kind of stuff and so can
you find yourself in the top 1,000
people in a certain field maybe that's
being a polymath and I'd rather than a
specialist a generalist maybe that is
your calling there's so many different
callings can you find yourself in the
top of your calling is a very
interesting question to ask all right on
Sibley sides so there's this thing
called obligate of Sibley side and the
other thing called faculity of Sibley
side so
simplified is nuts basically what
happens in biology is that a something
like this nazca booby which is this this
bird right here that you see will have
two will have two eggs and then when the
second egg hatches the sibling will kill
the the other sibling and kill the other
sibling because they are it was like an
emergency or was like it was a backup it
was like a backup as a second copy to
see if if if if the first one doesn't
work out or first one gets eaten or
whatever it may be so so so it kills it
so that it so that in again the mother
just watches the sibling kill the other
sibling it's crazy it's it's absolutely
nuts and so I thought this concept of
obligate of sibling was crazy and it
happens in pelicans owls cranes queen
bees parasitic wasps sand tiger sharks
actually cannibalized in the
spotted hyenas are kind of faculity
which means a faculty of simplified
facultative simplified means that it may
that simple aside may or may not occur
based on the environmental conditions
all right they spent a lot of time
talking about things like
mollusks newts and salamanders I want to
show you I want to show you this because
it's kind of it's kind of crazy that
they can like regrow their limbs so
newts and newts can regrow their limbs
you know this is what this is what they
look like and it's nuts because they
have the cells at the site of an injury
have the ability to undifferentiated ooh
strap idli and differentiate again to
create a new limb or organ so if you
think about that how can we regenerate
our limbs our eyes our spinal cords our
hearts our intestines our upper and
lower jaws it's absolutely nuts we can
potentially biomimic other species that
already exist on the planet which again
is just so so so interesting they were
showing a and so I really want to
continue looking into this more because
the more that you understand biology and
its complex systems the more humans can
understand themselves in the world and
further the more we can biomimic other
really smart creatures like how the
newts can do this or how some of the
best some of the Strongs and
neurological systems exist
in sea creatures and that's very
interesting yeah these these pyrrha
somes are so cool they were showing
these pyrrha somes all they were talking
about them there's this one that looks
like you know that looks crazy long like
that the giant Pyrus ohm was was found I
believe it was outside of New Zealand
that's where it was it was outside of
New Zealand and okay last couple of
thoughts on the way out I know this is
this is an extremely complex
nuanced conversation that happened so I
want to give it as much of its of its
doo-doo-doo multidisciplinary diligence
as possible there was this idea of you
know again err kind of press Joe on
hunting a bit was like you know what's
going on with hunting and and Joe's like
well there are certain populations of
animals that need to be controlled which
is true otherwise they will just
obliterate like bears will obliterate
the other elk and moose in the in
certain areas and so there's like a big
difference between like setting up a
bear trap versus actually going on
shooting went down with the rifle and
all this other nuance or a bow and arrow
like Joe practices it's just interesting
all of that nuance and so you know I
guess you know what are sort of the
ethical ramifications around these
things or what are the we've been doing
it for so long as hunters and gatherers
Oh what is it you know what has been
passed down biologically through us over
time I just want to say that Eric is
very playful he's so funny and Joe's
playful too it's just very interesting
how they're you know Eric's also
scientist and he's playful mathematician
economist etc so reasonable dialogues
becoming in a more and more popular we
see it in longer form conversations here
on our show on Joe Rogan show and I
think that's very interesting that we
have these longer form reasonable
dialogues that are popping up on the
world around the world a very scary
thing is the idea of exclusion that
Twitter YouTube etcetera do things like
you know they banned Alex Jones they you
know Google fired James d'amour and just
these ideas of exclusion you know they
have chief inclusionary officers well
what about the chief exclusionary
officers the ones that are trying to
identify these threats that exist and
exclude them from using the platforms
which is kind of crazy that that's
currently happening so here's an
interesting statistic out of the 535
senators and representatives in the US
Congress we have 12,000 719 lobbyists a
pair
that means there's 23 registered
Washington lobbyists per each
congressman or woman
what 23 lobbyists per Congress man or
woman that's a lot of money that is
moving into Congress men and women's
pockets that we were not expecting when
we first made the Constitution and the
judicial systems of our legislative
systems of our government in the u.s. so
we've went way past 1776 into two
thousand eighteen now approaching
nineteen where things are completely
different in governance structures
completely different way more money
being funneled into government it's all
influenced now so we have to be very
digging deep into this and following
things up because we're moving away from
mainstream media sources there's an
inverse relationship between the amount
of information technology and Internet
access that's been increasing in the
world and the amount of people that
watch mainstream media news outlets so
mainstream media is decreasing as well
while things like YouTube are picking up
more and more people are now getting
their news from things like podcasts a
vodcasts the news feeds on Google and
Facebook rather than maybe some of the
mainstream CNN Fox and whatnot taking in
all these perspectives so for example
like Eric it would be very interesting
Eric to start a podcast as well I've
urged Sam Harris to start doing video on
his on his show Jordan Peterson could
start one as well Elon Musk could start
one people like Michelle Obama or
Jennifer Doudna or other prominent women
could start one and that would be very
interesting Melinda Gates and that would
be very interesting I think and I think
it would pick up quite well in the world
if like teaching ping in China started
one that would be that would be very
interesting see what they would talk
about he sat down with Putin and they
talked on the show about how to best you
know collaborate and move forward people
have gotten on me a little bit recently
about wanting to
potentially get the United Nations
General Assembly to all agree to take
psychedelics together and to meditate
together I don't think that's a goal
that's too far out of of our future I
think that is a very possible future
that we have together and I think that's
how you get to a place of world peace
and in love and we'll we'll see if that
actually ends up happening Eric made a
really important point about taking all
of these perspectives in and finding
incompatibilities so rather than saying
like hey know like that perspective
doesn't mesh with that other perspective
you can take in although you can ask
them to you know give me all your
perspectives then they show you all
their perspectives then what you do is
you say okay now where are your first
principles where are how do these two
things exist when they're incompatible
in this X in this example and so that's
a good way to get people to to kind of
understand that they that the first
principles can't just mix and match
between things and change up and whatnot
so ok the last couple of thoughts
there's I this is I know this this one's
this one's quite long but this is also
very long podcast there was it was a lot
to talk about on this one yeah it can be
a little long sometimes but I'll finish
I'll finish this up Colbert is one of
the people that actually could
potentially start a podcast himself just
like Bill Maher could potentially not
start a podcast himself Tucker Carlson
couldn't start a podcast himself and I
think it's important to remember that
the reason why these guys can't start
podcast themselves is because they are
obliged to their mainstream media
outlets and Eric called that out Joe
called that out Joe kind of you know
said that that might not be true in some
ways but Eric you know pushed on that
which I thought was really interesting
because it's a it's a good point that
that the sort of late-night talk-show
hosts could start a vodcast because they
have only the ability to talk in
a small amount of time like five or
seven minute segments and they're
restricted by all of the components of
the multimillion-dollar sets and
executive producers and stuff that they
can only speak in such small amounts of
available perspective versus what a
four-hour conversation can take you the
example that was given was like Stephen
Colbert like you're Catholic but you
know the Catholic Church has been in big
trouble for the way that they treat
children that the way that you know
what's going on the sex with children
and stuff and you know the way that
Colbert would reply to that could
potentially risk his job and so that's
what Eric was pointing and I thought
that was interesting there's an there's
an you know the only person that's that
that that mainstream media is currently
playing with and from the intellectual
dark web is Jordan Peterson they're like
sending their best fighters against
Jordan Peterson right now but they're
not really challenging anyone else I
think there's gonna be more challenging
of the IDW in the future and I look
forward to - to watching that more and
and to seeing how that all plays out
there's something crazy going on with
follower counts right now that people
like Jack from Twitter and Kanye have
said things like you don't want your
social security number written on your
on your chest or the amount of money in
your bank account and that's the same
thing as having your followers online
there's a lot of nuance to that like
people worked really hard to gain a lot
of followers by saying important things
that other people like and so it can be
kind of crazy to try and and get rid of
that because if you do get rid of that
that can lead to a lot of other problems
like someone that has a same voice
that's similar to someone else where
that other person's voice is not as
powerful for progressing society forward
in some ways so I think that that's a
very important thing to take into
account the international dork web was
thrown around I thought that was just
this cute and funny Eric has a son his
name's Zev he has a he's 13 he has a
YouTube channel with a video on it I
went and watched it it's just the
powerful Jen's
kid there's these Genji kids popping out
like Zev is more you know in a way like
a little quieter but very articulate and
then and like Joe Josie was like 2 years
older than him and she is super bubbly
and extroverted and out and loud spoken
and stuff and there's just a really
interesting difference between their the
way that these Genji kids are evolving
out in the u.s. versus how a gen C kid
evolves out in in China it's a
completely different landscape for that
gen Z kid to evolve in and there was a
lot of other interesting things about
Copernicus moments finding those things
that only 1% of people believe in and
know and other really cool things like
like I was just I was just going and
looking into how crazy it was that when
I was looking at geoids and the surface
of Earth and finding those reference
points I was looking at the size of
things like Vesta and Ceres which are
the largest asteroids in the asteroid
belt and we're talking like 580 mile
diameters so that's like from San
Francisco to San Diego or from like
Paris to Berlin as an asteroid sighs it
was crazy looking at these things so
thanks everyone for watching are hugely
appreciated it's been a lot of fun
talking to you all about this really
nuanced episode of the Joe Rogan
experience featuring Eric Weinstein
again just remember when you think when
you think think multidisciplinary think
about all these complex perspectives
that we are discussing in long form for
our these 45 minute segments just trying
to unpack what they talked about go and
build the future go manifest your
destiny into the world there is so much
that we need you to build and bring to
it and have these stop provoking
Congress
with other people that are super nuanced
go watch that episode the links in the
bio go follow Eric and Joe their links
are in the bio as well
follow us we'd love to see more of you
watching episodes on our show as well
where we do feature some of the greatest
minds of our time and have nuanced
conversations with them about the future
of humanity thanks everyone
let's rebirth the public intellectual
join us thanks Ron for producing and
directing and we'll see you soon
peace
[Applause]
you